all right so this is sort of like a kind
of keep track segment as we hear more
and more about the people that knew and
were involved in exactly what the plan
was between the November 2020 election
and January 6th the day of the Trump
riots to try to steal the election from
the guy who really won it Joe Biden and
hand it over to Donald Trump in some
kind of a you can use the term coup or
Insurrection or whatever term you want
to use every time we hear from another
one of these Trump insiders we realize
it was much more premeditated than
initially was believed although there's
no question that I mean listen if for
the six months leading up to the
election they're basically telling us
we're going to say the votes were
invalid we're going to say that it was
all fraudulent Etc if they tell you that
for six months you should believe that
that's what they're going to do and
that's exactly what they did but there
is an incredible new article in the
daily Beast that now outlines Trump
economic adviser Peter Navarro
in an interview
straight up telling them what the plan
was and how he coordinated with Stephen
Bannon read the entire article we're
going to take a look at it the article
in The Daily Beast is called Trump
advisor Peter Navarro lays out how he
and Bannon planned to overturn Biden's
electoral win and it's exactly what we
believed and even worse a former Trump
White House official says he and
right-wing provocateur Steve Bannon were
behind the last ditch effort to try to
stop the certification of the 2020
election results and keep Trump in power
they even had a name for the plan called
The Green Bay sweep in his recently
published Memoir Peter Navarro Trump's
trade advisor explains how he stayed in
contact with Bannon as they put the
Green Bay sweep in motion with help from
Members loyal of Congress members of
Congress loyal to the cause
but in an interview last week with The
Daily Beast Navarro shed additional
light on his role and their coordination
with politicians like Paul gozar and
Senator Ted Cruz quote we spent a lot of
time lining up over 100 congressmen
including some Senators it started out
perfectly at 1 pm gozar and Cruz did
exactly what was expected of them it was
a perfect plan it all predicated on
peace and calm on Capitol Hill we didn't
even need protesters because we had over
a hundred congressmen committed to it
that commitment appeared as Congress was
certifying the votes you'll remember
Senator Cruz signed off on gozar's
official objection to Counting Arizona's
electoral ballots remember that there's
this
um this was an issue back in 2000 with
Al Gore and George W bush in that
election as well the way that these
objections work are that a member of the
House rises in objection and then they
are asked do you have the support of a
member of the Senate and typically the
answer is no in this case Cruz was the
Senate guy who was going to sign on to
that
um staffers For Crews and goes are did
not respond for requests for comment
there's no public indication whether the
uh January 6 committee wants testimony
or documents from Cruz or gozar but
they've only started to seek evidence
the last minute maneuvering never had
any chance of actually decertifying the
election results on its own a point that
Navarro quickly acknowledges but their
Hope was to run the clock as long as
possible
to increase pressure on Mike Pence to
send electoral votes back to six
contested States Now understand that
every time we learn more about the plan
it's the same story that we are hearing
now that we have the memo that was
written by uh Eastman the lawyer Eastman
and presented to the White House about
how this all could work one of the big
three points that was made was make it
so that we put pressure on Pence to
either reject the Electoral ballots from
certain States or even better even more
directly even more aggressively you
could say
um seat an alternative slate of electors
what they wanted Pence to do and of
course
legal most legal experts say Pence
couldn't actually do this what they
wanted Pence to do was say you know in
these different states Arizona I don't
remember the full list but it was like
Arizona Georgia Michigan Wisconsin maybe
Nevada uh they wanted Pence to say well
you know what
um we can't trust
these numbers and so instead of allowing
the Democratic electors to vote because
the Democratic candidate won the state I
am going to bring in an alternative
slate of Republican electors who will
cast their votes for Trump instead of uh
Joe Biden that was one idea uh Pence
couldn't really do that the other idea
that they floated was okay you don't
bring an alternative slate of electors
but you say because it's unclear who
really won some of these states we're
just going to take those electors off
the table and what that does is it makes
it so that the threshold for winning
instead of being 270 electoral votes is
some lower number ideally a lower number
which Donald Trump did have that that
was the other idea so when we look at
this article we realize this is part of
that same plan it was all coordinated
the legal opinions that Trump had in
front of them and the idea of putting
pence in a position to take action it's
the same thing that Peter Navarro and
Steve Bannon were working on
uh what else do we have here the Green
Bay sweep was very well thought out it
was designed to get us 24 hours of
televised hearings but we thought that
we could bypass the corporate media by
getting this stuff televised Navarro's
part in the ploy was to provide the raw
materials that came in the form of a
three-part White House report called the
immaculate deception and the Art of the
steel my role was to provide the
receipts for the hundred congressmen or
so who would make their cases who could
rely in part on the body of evidence I'd
collected to lay the legal predicate for
the actions to be taken and the article
points out ultimately states have not
found any evidence of electoral fraud
above the norm which is exceedingly
small I think it was uh
was it was it Wisconsin or Georgia that
found I think four dead people voted and
I think three of them just died after
submitting their votes you know we're
talking about numbers like that uh the
next phase was up to Bannon Navarro
describes in his Memoir Steve bannon's
role was to figure out how to use this
information what he called the receipts
to overturn the election result that's
how Steve came up with the Green Bay
sweep idea
the political and legal beauty of the
strategy was this by law both the House
and Senate must spend up to two hours of
debate per state on each challenge for
the six Battleground states that would
be as much as 24 hours of televised
hearing so that was the idea now
according to this plan
uh you can argue that the violence hurt
the plan
and what I mean by that is part of the
reason why the hearings didn't happen
and you didn't have 24 hours because
remember the day that a hundred thousand
of you at Simon it was actually about
1.3 million different people joined my
coverage of the January 6th Trump riots
my expectation on that day
was that we were going to see objection
after objection after objection
each with two hours of debate and that I
would step away from the coverage and we
would just stream the coverage and it
was going to go into the night 24 hours
maybe even 30 hours we were thinking the
reason it didn't happen is because of
the riots and so one could make the case
that this plan although it wasn't going
to work to steal the election that this
plan was derailed by the fact that the
riots took place now that would lead us
to the question well then why would
Trump incite the riots Trump has an
all-of-the-above approach Trump doesn't
have the sophistication and the the
ability for abstract thinking to realize
well this plan and the riot inciting
could end up conflicting and causing a
problem Trump's ideas just do do
everything do this and try to convince
Pence and then you know cause chaos and
ultimately because the debate stopped
because of the risk the physical risk of
violence to members of the House and
Senate this ended up not happening now
this ultimately wasn't going to work but
it might have actually gotten them those
24 hours of TV coverage that they wanted
so again it's all out in the open
they're admitting that this was the plan
to steal an election that they did not
actually win
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep I can't sleep in a hot room that's
why I love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable
climate-controlled sleep solutions to
sleep better their Flagship products are
the uler Sleep System and the cube sleep
system which is what I have both are
hydropowered temperature-controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees I like the cooler option I keep
mine at 60 degrees and it gives me a
great cool night of sleep no feeling hot
no more sweating I'm falling asleep
faster and it pairs perfectly with chili
sleeps weighted chili blanket which
keeps you cold on top too right now
chili sleep is running a special sale
you'll get 30 percent off everything
when you go to chiliesleep.com Pacman
the link is right underneath this video